hey we're here we did it dotnet rocks
I'm Carl Franklin and I'm Richard
Campbell and we're here with three
guests on our writing api's and all
about api's panel Sean Wildermuth is
here hi Sean hey there Irina's scorches
here
hi arena hi Heather downing is here
Aloha
and I'm we of course need to start this
show as we always start every show but
first Richard Campbell how you doing man
I you know busy is all get out man I got
nothin to complain about like his lost
to work on have been home a lot
obviously the streaming rig been
tinkering with it endlessly cuz they're
very popular right now
they are important to get all this stuff
tuned up you've been building some crazy
stuff I've been building really crazy
stuff so we're using V mix here to do
all this compositing and stuff and it
supports all these callers all these
callers are coming in right through V
mix and by the way panel somebody's
phone is on their desk and the
microphone is picking up the booth and
just might be but anyway yes I also AM
rebranding Puat studios to be in the
live streaming production business to do
sort of what we're doing here but with
multiple scenes in V mix and to take all
that off of the speaker's responsibility
so I actually give them an app where
they can switch their own scenes and
they can advance their slides and all
that stuff and they don't have to know
anything they can just go to a browser I
like that there was nothing to install
you literally sent me a link and Boop
Here I am yeah yeah I was aggressive so
anyway that's really good if you're
thinking of doing some online
conferences and online meetings and just
want to get beyond the zoom Brady Bunch
effect and do something a little more
spectacular I like a little pretty bunch
but now I'm with you yeah yeah all right
anyway let's get started with better
know a framework roll crazy means
awesome
and crazy
if anybody's confused right now if
you're watching the stream you didn't
hear the music it's because we don't
play the music when we record we added
in it later that's right that's solve
post-production effects and my multi
quarter stopped so I'm not sure why I'm
gonna try to restart it with a different
oh oh by the way I'm not recording
myself at all I don't have money doing
that do you want me to loop in you know
unless you don't care if we lose this
audio I don't want to lose the audio but
uh are you going to give me a minute
I'll just hop the microphone across
alright yeah why not yeah let me give me
once every little bit helps
yeah and you're right while we're doing
that I'll record I'll do the better no
framework so here's my better no
framework if you go to 1678 dot plop dot
me turns out that a juror has remote
rendering now or I don't know if it's
you know who owns it obviously azure
owns it but essentially the hololens -
you can essentially ship off rendering
of the hololens - to an azure service as
your mixed reality service so there you
go it solves the challenge of viewing
complex 3d models on hololens - without
losing polygon detail or spending
valuable time down sampling so if your
hololens isn't cutting the rendering you
can now just go use Azure remote
rendering and there's the link to it for
more information
1678 WAP dot me it's pretty cool I love
this whole new world of you know
shipping off CPU cycles to the cloud and
especially GPU stuff it turns out that
Asher has skews for VMs that have GPUs
so if you really want to spend a dollar
a day or a dollar an hour you know with
one of these big VMs that has Jeep
you stuff to do rendering to do
streaming to do all that stuff they're
there and a sure it's pretty cool what
do you guys hear me
yeah you can hear me yeah that's awesome
dude love it that's really neat and it's
pretty cool I don't have a hololens too
but if I did you know I'd be hooking it
up to Azure I'm still I have one of the
original ones but the the spousal
acceptance factor of that kind of cost
for its way is not yeah with being able
to do VR and mixed reality right now I
play beats amber twice a day to keep up
my you know energy and I'm interested in
building things that are more active in
Hollands example that's pretty cool okay
so hololens is actually part of your
exception exercise program it will be
when it gets here but right now I'm
using that so okay that's very cool good
all right well Richard Campbell who is
talking to us today well we only talk
about API so often but I grabbed a
comment here off of show 15:11 which is
from January of 2018 member 2018 when
you could go outside and everything yeah
and that's that was sure we doing Darryl
yeah babe you know take some pictures
it's fun
that was a show we did with Darryl
mellow talking about open API dotnet
right and that was you know specifically
a conversation around how we build eight
guys that work against multiple
languages so I think it's an absolute
talking point here and now so we were
clearly thinking about those kinds of
problems and an open API is course
continue to mature two-year-old
conversation now but still super
relevant and this comic comes from Max
who says with OPI let me say it again
with open API defining the behavior and
API in a standard way a standardized way
it makes communicating with it a breeze
I've really enjoyed working with it but
it could still be better certain
languages still don't integrate with it
particularly well and that - these are
super interesting just that problem of
you you think about we are continuing to
have more languages in our development
stacks right and we've had folks working
in Haskell as for back-end services have
you built api's that are tolerant to
that but they were able to call to it
reliably and so you know max is pressing
against this point two years ago but
still pressing against it now so it'd be
great to loop back on the subject so max
thank you so much for your comment a
copy of music oh by is on its way to you
and if you'd like a copy please to go by
write a comment on the website at rocks
comm or on the Facebook's when we
publish every show there and if you
comment there and I read on the show
we'll take your copy needs to go by and
definitely follow us on Twitter I'm at
Carl Franklin he's that rich Campbell
send us a tweet sign it virtually yours
nice that was deep man I'm dead I don't
think about that for a little you know
the coronavirus before we get into api's
let's stay human here for a little bit I
I was diagnosed with the corona virus on
March 29th but that was about a month
after I had symptoms which lasted about
a week maybe a little more so it
lingered that long and then I got
retested the first test I had was a
nasal swab which was quite a fundable
but you know I could deal with it
blowing my nose for an hour afterwards
no problem but the second one was a back
of throat swab right that that was just
last Thursday Friday and it's not
necessarily fun either when somebody
sticks a footlong q-tip up your nose
right and that's very special they know
you're gonna cough well this was back of
throat so they actually stuck it in the
back of my throat and initiated my gag
reflex I know you're gonna cop right
there done up in hazmat suits like you
know the the clear plastic shield over
the eyes turns you're gonna come at them
yeah
I just want to say that one came back
negative congratulations yeah so I know
I can do these bodies anybody want to
apply in a plasma yes we selling it
I'm a eBay nice that's all I got I
afraid people are gonna take you up on
it too right you wish that was a joke no
I know it's not it's kind of funny but
I'm perfectly willing to donate plasma
or blue yeah you're gonna be one of the
lab rats now right they're gonna be
taking blood from you as often as you
can give it and I personally know from
experience there's a lot of Carl
Franklin you can have some blood I'm
sorry Sean I cut you off you were gonna
comment there I know I just I've seen
those people all decked out I watched et
dirty 18 I see the extra-terrestrial oh
the bubble suits but I think one of the
things about evolving the testing is
getting way yeah we'll fix that it'll be
funny in the post don't worry yeah if
you're watching remember you guys are
doing it better than any of the
late-night talk show hosts having to do
things in their bedroom right yeah it's
true we got better I actually have a
lighter I can turn it up and
turn the slider down so I tried to bribe
this knob but it don't work one more
time Sean you were going to comment you
know you stayed again it get funnier
alright so what the heck are we talking
about building api's yeah let's do the
intro though you're still in an edit
point here yeah we're still you gotta
introduce these people that's true and
if I might add
I I did make the show in the editor too
so if you want to go oh okay yeah let me
look there even though our names are on
the screen here we go they are on the
screen well yeah but when you're in the
end I want to access your BIOS codes so
actually let me just add these BIOS to a
screen that I can read this is part of
watching the sausage being made folks
yeah that's what you paid for when you
yes we only sound clever on that on the
podcast because we have professional
editors arena skirt you is how you say
your last name is it better yeah it's
okay how would you pronounce it
squirtle score - I can say that but you
can see the Russian accent even when I I
pronounce it right move this over here
and we're ready to go all right all
right
it alright it's time to introduce our
esteemed panel first of all directly
below me you know for those who are
watching the video is mr. Sean
Wildermuth he has been tinkering with
computers and software since he got a
vic-20 back in the early 80s as a
Microsoft MVP since 2003 he's also
involved with Microsoft as an asp net
insider and client dev insider you know
there was such a thing as a client dev
insider I don't think there is any more
okay well anyway he's author of over 20
Pluralsight courses we've written eight
books as an international conference
speaker and one of the wilder minds you
can reach him in his blog at Wildermuth
comm he's also making his first
feature-length documentary about
software developers called
hello world in is that out it's not out
it's finished we're just in the film
festivals being cancelled process
awesome
well you can check that out at hello
world film calm and let's talk about
look geez my gun trying to read this
isn't the third person all right uh next
below me and to my right my left my
right to you you're aged Stage Left
yes states is Irena score - she's an M
Microsoft MVP for developer technologies
Software Architect
ctt plus technical trainer and Microsoft
certified trainer always in a quest for
latest trends and best practices in
architecture net and the world around it
our Dena score - has more than 700 hours
of delivered training workshops and
presentation being passionate about
domain driven design and micro services
we'll all their ups and downs she's the
founder of dotnet IOC did I say that
right yes
look at that almost yeah see you say yes
it's hard to know yeah yeah all right
she is the founder of dotnet Yash user
group where she tries to gather people
that are willing to share their
knowledge with others and Heather
downing you know what Brickley below me
hang on one sec just realized something
it's not a good time
Heather she's not on the show no it's
not you it's me we can be friends yeah
hang on just a second I apologize for
this guy's I just want to make sure my
recording is being recorded if you know
what I'm saying all right so I'll look
at that too because you know that would
be good for me that'd be good for you
yeah mines running good try to make this
work
hey hey hey all right good and on the
recording you'll notice that my voice
just changed that's because of where I
was recording everything's okay now so
Heather downing you know what maybe I
should do that whole thing again
okay all right so now it's time all
right so now it's time to introduce our
panel our esteemed panel Sean Wildermuth
has been tinkering with computers and
software since he got a vic-20 back in
the early 80s as a Microsoft MVP since
2003 he's also involved with Microsoft
as an asp net insider and client dev
insider he's the author of over 20
Pluralsight courses he's written eight
books he's an international conference
speaker and one of the wilder minds you
can reach him at Wildermuth comm he's
also making his first feature-length
documentary about software developers
today called hello world the film and
you can see more about it at hello world
film comm it's strong Wildermuth hey
there I better be here virtually
eeriness skirt 2 is a Microsoft MVP for
developer technologies Software
Architect C++ did I say that right CT
plus technical trainer and Microsoft
certified trainer always in a quest for
latest trends and host practices in
architecture dotnet and the world around
it arena has more than 700 hours
delivered trainings workshops and
presentations being passionate about
domain-driven design and micro services
with all their ups and downs she's the
founder of dotnet Yash user group where
she tries to gather people that are
willing to share their knowledge with
others
it's arena score - left to put in an
audience right yeah there you go and
Heather downing is a passionate coder
and entrepreneur she has experience
worth working she has experienced misael
again she has experience working with
Fortune 500 companies building
enterprise level mobile and dotnet
applications she spends her spare time
at tech conferences supporting the
growth of new developers of all genders
ages and backgrounds when not coding
Heather spends her time as a competitive
equestrian and learning the art of
mounted archery she's basically what's
cat Xena - you know that was it was it
yeah yeah okay Molly about yeah welcome
guys and I topic is building api's yeah
I mean it's not just the code of how to
build an API but it's the design of how
to build an API that's probably even
more important isn't it I think it is I
mean I starting from design first I
think is important but there's also that
I'm trying to push this idea of sort of
polyglot api's what I mean by that is we
have a lot of different API technologies
and they don't all work the best for
every different sort of scenario you
know rest works good from the web to the
server but inside uh between servers and
a micro service we probably want
something else if we want to go and do
streaming we might wanting something
else and so the idea of a mix of
different technology sort of like we did
with relational and non-relational
databases right I guess you know how you
lay these api's out and group them
together it's probably the first
decision that developers of api's
to make isn't it I think so
anybody got a comment on how how to
approach that the go-to option now it's
just pick something do HTTP arrest or
let's call it rest api's everywhere and
shove it to production I mean I've seen
a lot of folks doing this without
thinking the API design or the
constraints or the domain and anything
and they end up with a big ball of mud
not a monolid but smaller yep exactly so
I have a couple of things that I like to
look for when I consume an API so when
I'm going to build one naturally I want
to build something that I consume that I
enjoy right the interactive nature of it
I think for me the first one is it
really needs to be self descriptive and
discoverable like if you create an API
that has a whole bunch of shortened
versions of what their actual names are
nobody's going to understand what that
is and you're gonna have to go to great
lengths to do additional documentation
other than just allowing people the API
a take a look at what you got so you
know one get to get three endpoints a
dollar sign in basic yeah yeah good
Heather well I do think that there are
some good examples out there of some
api's that are fun to interactions
because they're free I think that we
sometimes fall into the hello world
scenario where we literally just copy
the structure that was put out in the
sample and we don't think about if
somebody knew nothing about what I'm
trying to build how would they be able
to you know handle this do the verbs
actually match what's happening I mean
if I do a post is it really a
I mean if I'm actually updating and with
that correct verb sometimes people just
overload verbs and have them do a whole
bunch of things and then that's very
confusing to the consumer of API so it's
important to be very very clear and just
follow some basic standards in Mike I
have a course on designing api's that
isn't about you know what technology is
being used behind the covers and I
encourage the students in it to start
with paper to literally design your your
eyes and design your payloads because a
lot of people worry about or think about
the design of an API being just the URL
right just movie / one or person dot -
but payloads are also part of that
design understanding what you want that
pillow to them food in different
scenarios I love that fog burnsy yeah
absolutely
they you know or on a whiteboard but to
physically write it out is to really
make people's hands hurt for their
complexity all right Nick if it's a pain
to ride out it's not any fun to type out
either sure and if it's not if it's not
clear on paper then it's probably not
intuitive right yeah what happens in a
lot of rest api is is people look at
their database schema and just mirror it
and that's not what you really need to
do right you know the difference between
what a user needs and what you have
happened to be stored in your
fifteen-year-old Oracle database might
be different use case right
ApS can be a use case like why would
somebody need this information or why
would somebody want to give us this
information they should be use case
based not this is the structure that
I've got - sörman for sure before you
even got yourself an api and talked
about that I think a good idea is to
have a separate model from the entity
like the entities or what we talked to
the database with but then have another
abstraction the model which is what the
API and the client work with
right Wow I agree I usually work from
the API back for those models though
because if if the need is to get you
know a customer what what does the user
really doing with that are they listing
the customer and the phone number just
so they you know someone can make a call
or even what the customer interview
order they've ever had right it can be
very easy to get bogged down and so
instead of like oh I need to make a
customer model that looks like the model
what what is the API actually serving
and really understanding that ahead of
time is hard because not everyone lives
in you know Greenfield or has more time
but I think it's worth the effort it's
worth the budget at us do you really
need to send foreign keys to the client
nothing you can filter out or even
sensitive data yeah right absolutely
yeah there's the security question oh
but I've got a token it should be safe
not from the user we forget that there
are vectors of security you know all
sorts sure but on the other side because
the rest api is and people don't do rest
ads it should be implemented graph QL
showed up and a lot of people are just
switching to graph kill because arrest
is bad and so on it's not that bad you
just implemented not so correctly
so I think a problem with over fetching
under fetching and so on it is in a
small part a problem of bad design over
that API or lack of design so I think
that's why go ahead a graph QL that's
why I think it has its use cases but in
my opinion now it has so much traction
that it shouldn't have I mean not so
many api's need to allow their clients
so much flexibility so we talked about
before a little bit but for those who is
the first time hearing about it why
don't you give us the elevator pitch
so graph QL is basically some similar to
JSON schema that the client will send
each and every time to specify fields
that it needs and they they said that
this way you just eliminate the under
fetching and over fetching problem over
with the REST API so you say I need the
first name and the email address and
from the address I need that field and
that's only the things that you'll get
back in response the deal is that you
won't have caching anymore you won't
have like verbs different kind of verbs
with different kind of headers you can
add headers but pretty much that is it
you have a single endpoint that you call
and call and get data and this gives us
to the client a lot of flexibility
github for example in the version 4 I
think they have this graph QL API but
not everyone is get up yeah lots of
graphic ul the QL meaning query language
is as sort of a in my mind where a where
it fits so I sort of I tell this story
about what technologies I think sort of
belong where and rest to the web this
natural I think graph QL is for
reporting for the most part because you
can set up a schema for the kinds of ad
hoc reporting that a lot of companies
will need and so going through the time
of building that you know information
database which is what it really is in
order to allow that that's great but
using it for general use I think it's
too easy to open up too much data to too
many people it's a issue of security and
of only pushing requirements from the
client side and then something like D
RPC I talked about as being inside the
data center or to something like IOT
because those are scenarios where hard
contracts can really be a benefit but
not necessarily do the web and so the
different technologies I think all have
their use cases but right now we're
trying to find one use
for everything Oh rest doesn't work in
every case really well let's bring in
graft um let it do everything Oh
let's bring in this other thing and let
it do everything let's go back to just
xml request from the web right well I
also really appreciate I do appreciate
arenas yeah Heather sorry make that
comment a product there's still there's
still use cases I think that RPC is
acceptable for so I mean I've definitely
run into a couple you know even though
it's been around forever
I actually in the right scenario it
works the best so I would caution you
against like bina showing any favorite
is that might know it's really hard and
dotnet because you know my favoritism is
like I want to build everything in
thought net but sometimes the answer is
not to do it in that net sometimes the
answer really is to build it in
JavaScript or build in a PHP or whatever
because it's set up that scenario just a
little bit easier well now you're just
talking crazy talk Miz down and good at
least he didn't say be calm I'm grateful
for that for example you read it for
example I was a I was talking about the
graph kill at the NDC London and I asked
okay how many of you are doing duress
api's at the beginning of my talk and
all the all the hands were up okay I'm
doing great api's and then I talked
about the rest and hate OS and
everything that should be there and then
asked again who is doing duress api's
now only to him it was very clear that
well we we take us for granted and say
yeah okay it's bad now it's not that bad
it suits a lot of purposes if you do it
correctly I mean hate OS and researcher
presentation and everything it has a
meaning so or even with versioning I
mean I've seen so many API is having v1
in the URL and dying with v1 there and
come on
either I expect a b2 if you haven't got
a minor like something that will not
break your scheming and that's fine but
in general I expect the moment anything
changes
I wanted me to I want the next V next
well I mean is that the basic definition
of a v2 is this is a breaking change and
I don't want to mess up my existing
users so I have that v1 there so they
can keep working really think about
changing it and they have to think about
hosting them side by side or do they
host them forever to the sunset an
earlier version there's all these things
you have to start thinking about if
there's gonna be versioning which I
encourage you to have make sure that you
think about what is the path to support
multiple versions it was a path to
sunset
geez we should do a show on versioning
shouldn't we Richard although it was
also the first show back since you got
Corona and so I think we spent the first
half just talking about the world were
in but when junkie yeah well when John
yeah when John skis talks about
versioning you and I both stop stop and
listen because he's definitely battled
that battle but and I doubt I've lived
in Enterprise Service bus projects long
enough though
this is what we're up against like you
just can't you've got API use forever
you don't love fixes yes but once people
are consuming it I can't tell you that
we've ever turned one off we monitor
this if there's no traffic left but like
every single time you shut it off
somebody screams sooner or later
typically later when it's much harder to
turn it back on and if nobody's using it
it costs you virtually nothing it's a
good way to yep but the problem is that
most of the companies are the systems of
client apps and the api's are owned by
the same company or teams they do not
have the problem of versioning like
something that needs to be there and
work
they will just go and change the client
up the angular reacts or whatever to
match the API and it's kind of the face
the purpose Richard well I'd make oh
yeah I guess this time isn't it yet and
I'm gonna interrupt for one moment for
this very important message
you
and we're back it's Donna rocks I'm Carl
Franklin he's Richard Campbell and those
are an amazing esteemed panel did I say
that I said that I would be funny that's
it but I did it straight and I'm not
fixing it you can live with it it's all
good and this is another on your own
there you go
and in another world we would be in
Porto together right now sitting on a
stage having this conversation face to
face with a bunch of wires and
microphones and an audience and instead
we're doing it online with an audience
I'm in the slack Channel folks are
watching streaming it over YouTube and a
variety of other services I'm glad we're
able to do this together and I'm glad we
gave you to put it on but obviously been
a little more complicated to pull off
this this API forever thing is it's
interesting that I think we often put
stuff up and just have no consideration
for its impact long-term so I wonder if
a lot of time it doesn't have much
impact long term what what happens in
API that nobody ever wants to use
it's it's an interesting question
because I think you do have to plan for
api's to live for a long time I think
one of the points my other panelists
were making was more about how the
versioning stands and whether we should
do it or not I know the right companies
don't quit at all I talk a lot about
versioning in to get it out of the URL
because I in order for someone to
consume a new version that means
changing every Earl in their entire
application versus right so now you're
now you're punishing people who wanted
to use the new thing and so your
adoption of v1 doesn't go away as much
because you know if your next change
isn't a breaking change you might want
to move everyone over without them
having to opt in to you right okay or
arenas point before the break was you
simply forced people to use the new
version by taking the old version away
it's been updated its you're broken now
well you better use the new version huh
am I wrong area that's basic what you
were implying not quite I was saying
just because the company's owned the
client apps that are consuming those
api's and are building the api's then
they have leverage and control about
changing stuff so this way they are not
forced no in a way to change to beat you
and then think about deprecating fields
or URL or forcing their consumers to
switch to the new version so that's why
I think they do not even think about I
don't change into v2 in the life cycle
of the project so here's a question then
maybe for your listeners is are you
building an externally facing API or are
you building one in a closed ecosystem
that's like what are people building
right now because a lot of times
and unless you're bigger like your
stripe or you know you are digitalocean
or something like that you may not have
an externally facing API it's just going
to
for like the multi divisions you've got
going on inside of your company and that
does change things of course you can
cheat if it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't follow some basic protocols
you know when it comes to how you build
stuff especially as you have turnover
with all your developers you don't want
the learning curve to be more difficult
it also diversion aid me I'm sorry sorry
make a point for ten minutes but I feel
like it's more like a changing over to
the to the consumer of the API so so you
finish your thought and then well then
I'll change it over okay great
this versioning story inside your own
API inside your own applications I think
is still important especially as people
are starting to look at micro services
because we want to be able to deploy
them individually not have a whole
release you're going to want to have
maybe some older components of micro
services using v1 where's the new stuff
is using v2 and having them both
otherwise your API becomes the singular
focus of all we need to change and
redeploy your entire micros purpose yeah
if you're consuming api's and your let
me see let me say it again as a consumer
of api's you're usually writing a
service you know some sort of class or
some sort of module that you can call
those api's through it's a really good
idea and I know it just seems like
obvious but if you have one field that
is the base URL for all of your api's so
that way if you want to change versions
it's one variable rather than going
through all of your service calls or
whatever it is in trying to update those
and it may seem like obvious now but you
know develop you know how developers are
they just charge ahead and build out a
class with a bunch of static methods and
the api's are hard-coded in there no put
him in a config file and now you can you
know comment out the the base URL and
the config file just changed make one
change and now you're on a different
version and that's why we're sending the
base URL is is the the version entity
right
I would extend that to also you know the
creating of that base URL would include
the connection to HTTP mostly because
often you're going to want that same
place to put in your headers maybe
that's a token for authentication maybe
it's a header for versioning maybe it's
just some other piece of information but
centralized that creation of your
connection to that server and that's
going to include base URL that's going
to include the other sort of overhead of
that call that you may need is that's
becoming more and more common I have a
thought as you've been talking about how
people approach you know just building
just the basic like URL there remember
the longer that an API whether it's
inside of your firewall your company or
its externally exposed the longer it
lives the more opportunity there is for
exposing it and it getting spammed or
you know misused so every time I build
something now I have to put on my hat
that says how can somebody misuse this
API for either information or to bring
down my server or whatever it is so
that's the first thing I look at is can
somebody like how would someone misuse
us if they got into our system and so
that's where rate limiting is important
and logging becomes important if you
start noticing the same ip Astarte is
spamming you all the time that may be
something that you want to be alerted
about and that's not something that most
developers start with they don't think
Oh what happens if somebody gets in line
API is very defensively before you get
one way to mitigate that if you're not
doing it yourself is to use something
like as your API service so that you new
set up rules that will automatically do
rate limiting so you can guarantee that
you know your cluster doesn't get
brought down or one of your one of your
servers gets brought down by spam those
there's so many good thing I actually
did a deep dive into the API service
working on a project and had to do all
the research into all the filters and
say oh yeah
really it's also a fill-in component
there too right but you can you can
charge people for utilization yep
it's important to think about that and
that's not something that was originally
thought about even as some of the
banking software that I helped create
and in the beginnings anyway is that we
didn't think about what happens when our
our mobile app gets released and now our
api's are getting hit all the time by
people who want to know all the time if
they got their stimulus check if they
got whatever are we to be wary handle
minutes
you know that's just that's the good
traffic let alone the people who are
trying to sniff around and see if they
can get you know it's forced in a little
bit of that URL and they didn't really
lock it down very well so that's just
something that you know throw a little
chaos engineering at your API can you
can you break it this that's the first
place sister it's just a runaway piece
of software and deploy it on something
bigger than a Raspberry Pi yeah I told
the story before but in the old days I
got the local telco put up an SMS
service right this is back in like the
candy bar phone days where literally
text messages were real text messages
and yeah I wrote a little app that
screwed up and sent me 32,767 text
messages in about a second and you had
to delete each one by hand so it's yet
takes me about an hour to get to tier 3
tech support cuz tier 1 and tier 2 have
no idea what the heck I'm talking about
when I get to the tier 3 gaga hi you
know I've been experimenting with your
API to accidentally set myself 30 2007 o
67 he goes oh it's you which he clearly
decided I actually have a signed integer
that's right it was a sign small integer
but yeah the clearly the guy on the
other end was the guy who just seemed
that come in and went wow it's like okay
I'm gonna lead him on this and you'd be
I only have to delete the first one is
it literally only load them one at a
time into the phone and don't do that
again
good you know rate limits yeah I really
hate deeply nested
so imagine if you had a really nested
response from that API on top of how
many responses you're getting oh my
goodness I did the same thank you see a
mail server a long time ago so I feel
your pain
Asia AWS or whatever cloud provider
gives us some pieces of technologies to
put on top of our api's but nowadays I
get a feeling that developers I look oh
I'm using that I do not need to design
my API properly or I don't care about
status codes or whatever I'm just using
that when that piece of technology is
there to enforce what we already do I
think like lazy approach to do it that
way for sure correct it also you don't
know what the future brings maybe you
need to scale things up and you have to
move it
for some of it for some reason to
something else completely that has been
the case for a lot of our clients before
I move to author that they're like you
know it as your too expensive we kind of
deal with Amazon we need to move over so
what does that just under eight guys
right now this should be something that
could be self-contained enough that you
should be able to pick it up and move it
and it still has some basic
thoughtfulness around it and remember to
design your api's with status codes in
mind that's another piece of the disease
in case anybody doesn't know there is
more than 200 and 500 those aren't the
only G status codes there's four hundred
and nine yeah comics with your favourite
status code yep for 16 reminds me of
that joke where a bunch of friends get
together all the time and they keep
telling the same jokes over and over
again what's like richer than me and
yeah and instead of calling out the the
jokes they just numbered them all like
ha ha ha
I mean I do feel that way a little bit
whenever I get a 401 that I didn't
expect nice
exactly I'm looking at the YouTube
stream and there was question from hens
Jurgen Bakken and said I hope it didn't
mismatch earning too much ends yeah who
said who asked should you design your
API was to be infrastructure independent
and I think this speaks to exactly what
Irena was saying which what happens if
we have to shift to AWS it does does
that make sense to actually make it into
infrastructure independent at least
planned for what you would need to do
when you need to move infrastructure
right I'm not sure this is like the old
the old story of writing a database
extraction layer in case you need to
change database servers this is a race
their cost is worth it at least have a
plan
if you if you if you aren't going to
completely and and hence makes the
example of if you use API management in
Azure that's an answer specific feature
if you're shifting to AWS how are you
gonna rate limit yeah exactly and so you
have to decide how much you're gonna
hand over in any situation as part of
the reason why you know containerization
is such an interesting concept to me
because it forces a developer to still
think it doesn't matter where this lives
it just matters what it does and then it
can move from there now I'm not saying
you shouldn't take advantage of things
like as your key Balt or anything like
that you know to interact with your
application you don't want to be putting
everything inside of what you're
building but as a agreed as John
completely taken afternoon and just say
let's pretend that we scale let's
pretend that we take off because
everybody's buying our products how are
we gonna scale this let's just take it
out from the end to say this is what we
would do and that gives you also a basic
idea of what to say when you go to the
higher-ups and saying this is probably
what it's going to cost if and when we
scale
yeah it's the old startup joke where you
know you create a startup you turn it on
on the internet the first 10 sales like
oh my god this is great the first
hundred thousand is like oh this is
gonna be amazing when you hit a million
we're like we can't afford to sell it
anymore just sell anything uh this also
feels very YAG needed me to plan for
moving between clouds the chances are
low I think I'd rather you I don't want
to write more code than I have to and it
would be one of the costs of migrating
is yeah we're gonna have to retool how
we relate and and fill out our API
access we're not saying you have to
build it all just give it some thought
just like yeah we're sure where would
you like to put that responsibility yeah
and acknowledge that there's a hot yeah
I mean yeah yeah separate issue
it's like Joe's discount shark Kage's
com exactly by the way in her store the
other day they don't sell any containers
they just have boxes and lids I don't
know what they do him yeah sorry I
talked over here every day Arina know
what I wanted to say is that when a vet
all talking it's a bit extreme there
might be some business in areas where ok
you do not want to be clouds provider
locks but what what if something happens
I don't know and you do not have the
money to pay clouds infrastructure and
then you decide to go on premise
somewhere your Apia still needs to be
working I mean without the API
management and everything in here you
can switch from a jerky vault
to I don't know holding things in to
environment variables somewhere and that
machine so then you're ready to switch a
few yeah there are so but it also is
it's sort of a fault savings I'm really
gonna save money moving on premises but
I have to now
write my own API rate-limiting player I
mean there's a library for everything so
I agree I don't want to create my own
stuff that way I think it's important to
use things that are standard for sure
but I have seen too many clients just
get burned where they're like we have to
just start over from scratch because now
we moved host providers like it's yeah
it's and it wasn't necessary it
literally they just you could have
contained the damage a little bit it's
enough to be as dramatic that's what I'm
getting at but they wanted to rewrite it
in react so how are they gonna do it
well I also think that whole you know
I'm having problems in rest I'm gonna
redo this in graph QL way and it's like
your own problems follow you anyway
right it's like but you get left alone
for a few weeks to retool it which is
all you really wanted it's the people
stop yelling yeah I know that work I
know that there's a little bit of a
love-hate relationship right now graph
QL but we need to pay attention and get
good at it because it's not gonna go
away it's definitely something that's
being embraced specifically by the open
source community and so that's something
that we should have an opinion about the
right way to arenas point to use
something like rack you know phrase now
go ahead Richard sorry I just wanna make
sure everyone realizes that rest is
becoming the JavaScript of API is right
it's the hated thing that actually runs
yeah nobody does did well I'm gonna
paraphrase in a comment here from Rico
in the in the chat where he's asking us
compare arrest and and and graph QL but
you also mrs. G RPC and we haven't
talked about G RPC at all yeah so what
about G RPC in the API were either way
Shawn its G our pc pc o in it PRT let's
check again that's why i have we're not
your words around for you but that's not
gonna do with that so er PC is
interesting and I think I think a lot of
people like graph QL think it's the next
thing that can fix wrist and I just
don't see a er PCs contract-based it's
actually a more similar to WCF in some
ways it's binary and so I think it's a
great solution inter data center so
server to server especially in micro
services but also because it works so
well in resource constraint scenarios
that IOT server to IOT is a beautiful
place for it because the serialization
overhead on an IOT device you just don't
want to have to deal with Jason
serialization in that case sure and
because it lives in the same place that
something like raster graphic UL do you
don't have to reinvent the way you
authenticate it or authorize it or it's
just more HTTP it just happens to use a
- B - instead of being able to work on
HTTP one
so I think comparing rest with wit graph
QL is like comparing onions to oranges
no pun intended but yeah I mean they fit
a purpose scenarios well-defined
scenarios but I think people should take
a step back and understand the
technology before throwing in to using
it into production
yeah graphically is worse it has
specific scenario where it shines but
don't say that rest is bad don't say oh
you know query ingress ApS back sucks
I'm going to graph gel I mean there is
no data for wearing data oh yeah I said
recommend it to a customer recently
because their use case was being able to
query from Excel and Excel support so
data out-of-the-box doesn't support
rescue Elliot doesn't report breast and
so even though I'm not a huge fan of Oh
data on the whole this was the right
tool for them and that's what I yes I
wish people would think about more is
what is the right tool and you know it
isn't about oh this doesn't work well
for me like Richard said so well you're
gonna take your your debt with you yeah
yeah it's sort of like thinking I'm
gonna get divorced and I'm gonna find
the right girl no you're gonna you
remember that whole stack of magazines
that all those issues you have they're
coming with you you're moving with them
already got there Sean I think he
delivered on that one I appreciate that
but you know it this is sort of like an
aesthetic that we profess on.net rocks
over and over again which is there's a
lot of stuff to know and the more you
know the better informed decision
so it pays to have someone on your staff
whose sole purpose is party you know to
research these things and find out what
what does that do you know what is what
is graph QL do what is OD on how and how
would that fit in and how would that fit
in to us right exactly so it isn't
something that you can just take an hour
on lunch and go google your way around
and you know try to make a decision
about a technology you have to grow your
seniors or your mids in like the next
level this gives them a task hey give us
you know that options
I remember for my mobile group that I
was in I was in a group at the company
before octet where it was my job to say
okay here's the client thing tell us
which platform it should be and why so
that means you get a couple weeks to go
and play around with react and native
stuff and whatever you want just give us
a couple of options as what you think
would work and that is that really grew
me in terms of my own chops so that's a
good way to do it and of course you know
it also means that you're more talented
people who have a little bit more
responsibility also don't get weighed
down with additional Rd that that allows
the next person to grow sure yeah
but I really appreciate this I presume
the panel all sports is that it that you
have you're not going to use only one of
these communication layers for
everything yeah and not is it it's you
know it's there are hammers and there
are screwdrivers you're calling them
from so relate that's all the really
matters all right
how're we doing on time through the last
couple of minutes friend yeah two
minutes all right well we just have a
couple minutes left does anybody have
any final words or any out there Sean
you said we're not government you said
you had a course Sean that you you do I
have a API design course and and
Pluralsight courses are free for the
month of April so this is the chance to
go yes April April okay
and it's really people while we're
recording this it won't be when we
publish it oh yeah that's right that's
right
so go pay for the course yeah yes now
I've a design course I also sort of want
at and I've been getting angry about
development for a long time so I decided
to start have having some rants so if
you go to youtube / Sean Wildermuth
you'll see a new series I'm doing I'm
just complaining about software I like
everything about that I love that is
there anything that you want to throw
out there any resources the world wide
web technology and dogs and I just want
to say that every developer should make
an informed decision not choose the
bright and shiny stuff that goes around
and changes very often I mean just
knowing about a piece of tech will allow
you to take the best decision for your
project I mean old data is a good idea
it depends no no no no make the bad man
stop well I do have several YouTube
videos out about working with api's and
of course I just got started on twists
if you want to follow me that's my name
on twitch yeah
Coraline :
yes Bella uu o r ra o YN e it's a
throwback to Tron Legacy so yes and if
you want to follow me a twitch and we
can kind of create scenario-based Inc
guys together so that you can kind of
learn directly but I also have several
YouTube videos on it I think what I
really want to impress upon everyone is
to secure your api's from inception from
the very first time when you just do a
template at API and push it somewhere
make sure you immediately secure it
because you will forget and then you'll
get audited over projects where somebody
forgot to put some sort of security pin
plates and yeah that's never a good look
and it's never a good thing face so just
do it upfront as just part of you set up
your repos set up the security from the
beginning and you don't have to think
about it anymore it's just in there very
good and you have the last word so I'd
like to thank you all for listening to
dotnet rocks and I'd like to thank Sean
welder me arena scored - and Heather
downing thank you all in Richard and I
would like to say we'll see you next
time on dotnet rocks
you